la vie nocturne c'est terminé pour
lutter contre le coc vide 19 la
municipalité d'asnières a opté comme de
nombreuses villes en france pour le
couvre-feu pour manuel aeschlimann maire
de cette ville des hauts-de-seine
cette mesure était évidente au vu du
comportement irresponsable de plusieurs
individus dans une police municipale 24
heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 qui
intervient dans le cadre de la lutte
contre le coronavirus naturellement et
puis également en soirée avec l' arrêté
de couvre-feu qu'on a pris de 22h à 5h
du matin la police municipale la semaine
dernière a fait beaucoup de pédagogie
dorénavant elle a le droit de mettre des
procès verbaux partie on va faire
respecter les autorisations de sortie
pour le wild qui sont qui sont plus en
plus limité la sanction ces bases-là
mesure de garde à vue en trois fois à
contrôler dans les 30 jours c'est museau
reygadas garde à vue avec 3750 euros
d'amendé et à risque de six mois
d'emprisonnement
en effet que
place
je suis pas de contact avec l'extérieur
puisque mon déjà ma conjointe
actuellement les dents mémétique mois
donc on exposait tout lé d'autun claude
mon enfant il a été car enfin il est
qu'il est il a été quart temps n'a pas
écarté mais voilà du coup je le vois pas
depuis quinze jours quoi mais si on peut
toujours attention aux étages parce
qu'il ya les jets projectiles et on
reçoit généralement des bouteilles d
hiver d'objets
pas assez malin je te dis pas c'est
malin pour nous à l'espace qu'on a on a
un manque a pris la fuite à notre vue
inutilement juste pour une attestation
qui étaient pas bonnes il va aider à
baliser est ce qu'on peut faire prendre
autant de risques aux habitants entre
autres de la commune où on travaille
juste pour avoir envie de fumer une
cigarette prend bien monsieur que j'ai
pas le droit mais à partir du moment où
dans le fait aussi vous jouez tout c'est
la transmission du virus à se propage
croatie moi je reste dans mon coin je
suis ma cigarette chez sita uniquement
une attestation qui est pas valable avec
une pièce d'identité tu vas pas partir
en courant d'accord voilà sa peau plus
de moments que tu as fait un effort
d'avoir une attestation voilà parce que
je vais tous les jours c'est déjà
souhaité tous les jours mais je le
crains qu'il te plaît
ok bah tu dois te mettre en conformité
donc là tu n'étais pas tout seul
voilà donc on est de mauvaise foi on est
de mauvaise foi
et quand vous sortez là quand vous
sortez je vous rappelle également qu a
le le couvre-feu l'homme arrêté
municipal depuis mardi soir 22 heures 5
heures du matin interdiction de sortir
souvent critiqué la police est
maintenant saluée par l'opinion publique
dans ces périodes de crise sanitaire
[Applaudissements]
ces moments qui font plaisir
c'est bon par rapport à notre métier on
voit un peu tout et c'est vrai que ces
deux cantons et remercié comme ça et ça
fait ça fait chaud au coeur
[Musique]
à